[Music]
so
i agree we need to give israel more
money no no no no no no i meant the
opposite i meant the opposite oh nobody
should be getting money okay
oh my god dan crenshaw just [ __ ]
empty eye hole perked up right now
don't do this i'll say this to the
federal reserve and started stuffing
money in his eyes did you see the video
that he made saying he wasn't in the
world economic forum yeah but you are
though you're on the website you're the
young leaders council did you see his
absolute
hold on who sent it to me uh alex rosen
sent it to me i think yeah well i was
talking to him about it last night but
he didn't send me the link yeah i was
talking about it too hold on hold on let
me find it here i think it was him that
did it
uh then crenshaw
no no [ __ ] i should have had it i'm just
guys somebody sent it to me please
please i i know that i should have had
it and this is my [ __ ] is frozen you
know what no this is frozen's fault hey
frozen's not here you know frozen was
here we would have had this
uh i'll find it i promise he'll find it
guys
damn it you could talk yeah no i was
talking to alex about that last night
and he's like you know he said he's not
in and i'm like found it but he he is on
their website like they just they put
these videos out and lie because they
know 60 of the people gonna watch it and
just believe them
so the latest conspiracy theory about me
and by the way this is i want to point
something out this isn't the latest
conspiracy theory about you we've been
talking about the world economic forum
thing for a really long time the problem
was most people were paying attention to
alex stein and cassidy campbell got up
on your [ __ ] grill and then they've
everything that they talk about with you
they keep tagging the world economic
forum and now you have to address it
look there are many and they're kind of
hilarious and people love to click on
them
one of the latest ones is that i'm
secretly part here's another crazy sorry
before i play this here's another crazy
one there's a conspiracy theory that dan
crenshaw said
that america is only here because of
israel that's a conspiracy theory
he didn't say that
click on them
one of the latest ones is that i'm
secretly part of the world economic
forum nobody said secretly nobody said
secretly no you're open you're on the
web openly on it yeah
that's right so the conspiracy goes like
this um even though i vote uh completely
opposite to their values everything i
say and do is completely antithetical to
everything that it means to be a real
conservative no i know
is that where you were going with this
because that's again
not conspiracy really
the world economic forum stands for that
there's this belief that secretly i'm a
card member
i didn't think you have a card
yeah i don't think you actually get it
it's like it's like an app yes
um it's not true
never collaborated with them there's no
correspondence with them there's no
membership there's nothing
the reason people latch on to this for
those of you then why were you honest
why were you on their website yeah you
were on there why were you on their
website you we're on there are you not
on their way right next to tulsi gabbard
hey roy so are you on the world economic
forum not to mine you're not part of the
young leaders movement mm-hmm but tulsi
gabbard is sbs
dan franchise yeah no don't know and you
probably don't even know what the world
economic forum is
oh cause we're stupid
he does this a lot because we're dumb
idiots he he he talks down to you and by
the way talks down his constituency
talks down to little little kids because
they mention superman
there's nothing
the reason people latch on to this is
because they don't crush puss and have
[ __ ] girlfriends bro we know well we
don't questions we don't
push and we don't get hot girlfriends
we're all so stupid oh you're awesome
we're all so stupid you know why i
forgot because i'm stupid we're sort of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] for those of you don't
you probably couldn't find davos
switzerland on a map you pleb
you know i'll tell you what he can't
find 3d glasses that work for him
latch on to this for those of you who
don't know and you probably don't even
know what the world economic forum is
you don't even know you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he dan crenshaw is literally the guy
dan crane shows the guy in white run
that's like have you ever been to the
cloud district oh am i kidding of course
you haven't i know exactly
bro you're such a piece of [ __ ] dan did
he please tell me he's getting ratio
with this now too
cause he's been spiraling lately i don't
know he posted it on instagram oh cause
what's great about um what i love about
crenshaw is um
the more people pick at him
the more he forces normies to not like
him because he's he shows how unlikable
he is he can't help himself it's it's i
love it
the reason people latch onto this for
those of you don't know and you probably
don't even know the world economic forum
is
a few years ago in 2019 like every year
they publish a list of like up and
coming leaders and they put me on the
list i rose to fame very very quickly
humble brag bro listen
to the verbiage
of this elected official who by the way
is a
public servant
is saying i rose to fame
he says things when you hear dan
crenshaw pay attention to this because
the between the line stuff with him is
always the best you know oh he is
cleaning up his instagram replies too oh
yeah so he did it on instagram
because he can delete all the [ __ ]
the bad comments
so
everybody's sucking his [ __ ] dick in
the comments
but
it's got 62 000 views and all the
comments are positive
but not but only like 500 comments which
means that there's like thousands that
are getting deleted so he's
a [ __ ] liar is what he is now here's
listen to his excuse publish a list of
like up-and-coming leaders and they put
me on the list they rose to fame very
very quickly uh in 2019 and so they
added me to the list
there's no correspondence that occurs
there's again there's no membership
there's no meetings never been to davos
you've never been to davos yet
and
i think we need to put the conspiracy
back in the box
listen how he talks down to you he's
everybody watching this if people that
probably voted for him are watching this
i'm sure i mean statistically speaking a
couple
look how he talks to you i like what he
thinks you are i also think that he's
trying
even though he doesn't like trump he's
trying to pull off a trump type thing
he's jesus but like he's not trump never
called all of you losers that would be
you know what i mean like like dan
thinks that that's how you do it
is you just talk down to everybody
whereas trump never talked down to you
he was always talking down to some dude
you didn't like and you're like okay
that [ __ ] rule here's here okay
here's something fun merce let's do a
little thought experiment with you so
he's saying that they added him on on
this list he's there's no correspondence
if tomorrow
okay you were to wake up and on the
world economic forum it said one of the
up-and-coming people is mike shealy you
would immediately that evening i would
be in a panic screaming on like i'd be i
hired an attorney immediately i would be
like you tell them right now take my
[ __ ] name off of there i would be on
i would be going live in the middle of
the afternoon doing an explanation on my
on god i've never spoken to any i don't
know what they're doing so basically
what he's saying is is that
this is how i read it that he silently
knew he was there because it helped him
get a little street cred on the
globalist side of things because he's a
globalist
side of things i vote this way mr okay
mr red flag laws aha who's now all
changing his tune because he's [ __ ]
got so much [ __ ] uh you got it mr
[ __ ] warhawk it's not gonna stop
danny boy small government 40 billion
dollars to ukraine hey you know what how
about this dan i don't give a [ __ ] if
you're on the world economic forum how
about that there's a billion other
reasons to dislike you you want to know
why because let me tell you something
dan your piece of [ __ ] you use your
little [ __ ] injury in iraq to send
more 18 year olds to get their [ __ ]
faces blown off because instead of
[ __ ] learning your lesson and being
like you know what we have to be really
careful about what we do instead you go
i lost my eye these little pieces of
[ __ ] he's like bart simpson saying we
need another vietnam to thin out their
ranks a little bit vietnam that's what
you are
you warhawk piece of [ __ ] and by the way
i think you are a globalist piece of
[ __ ] and i think you can't stand anybody
talking to you because you think you're
above them but guess what you're just
another [ __ ] guy that came out of the
military and as a [ __ ] idiot like
everyone that's upside down in a goddamn
darts charger right now while they cheat
while you're on deployment the only
difference is those people still have
both of their eyes so go [ __ ] yourself
dan crenshaw i am sick of this guy i
have been sick of this guy for so long
he was worse than a [ __ ] room full of
[ __ ] schumer's and pelosi's and all
those people because all those people
are [ __ ] rats and they're up front
you're a piece of [ __ ] that'll stab
anyone in their back to get ahead that
way you could be on ironically by the
way a show called the view you could be
you could [ __ ] be hanging out with
pete davidson right that same danny
crenshaw you want to be on tv right you
want to be on tv and go look at that war
hero [ __ ] gi joe go [ __ ] yourself dan
crenshaw all right i hope you get
primaried i'd rather i'd rather vote for
the bluest [ __ ] person that runs
against you than you ever again i don't
vote for you but if i did you piece of
[ __ ] i [ __ ] hate this guy
where it belongs
and uh let's try not to turn our
politics into the terry springer show
thanks everybody
let's not turn our politics is that on
twitter that was
and i know he put it on instagram but
did somebody oh well but it's gonna but
it's cassidy posted it so it's gonna be
everyone in the comments okay so he's
gonna be just as biased as his instagram
right like cassidy posting these things
well
uh and then cassidy says dan says he
doesn't know anything about the world
economic forum
we sort of danced around the topic of
the world economic forum um
the great reset we've talked about a
little about the covet conspiracy to
shut everything down
we got the border issue at hand
where do you see the the great reset
right now and where is it where is it
going over the next four four to six
years i don't know if i danced around it
i just don't know anything about it i
mean there are a lot of subjects that
touch the great reset or at least the
philosophy of the great you don't know
anything about them trying to
effectively change the entire planet
yeah because either you're lying about
that not knowing about it or
you shouldn't have the job that you have
because you're so stupid you don't know
it exists so which one is it i've never
been to davao you know bro don't lie
yeah i i just don't know much about it
okay again i don't i don't care either
then you're not good at your job you
don't know about the great recent and
you don't care that's right folks those
people that are worried about an entire
global government taking you over and
controlling you and pushing you and
doing everything they want and tracking
you in a [ __ ] global credit system
and all that stuff which is actively
happening right now and it's being
tested all over the goddamn planet you
people that are worried about that dan
crenshaw doesn't care about that because
it's not ukraine or israel don't you
understand have you tried being
ukrainian have you tried being our
greatest ally
because then he cares about you not
texans
you know
i i think we're obsessing over it on the
right a little bit
you guys you're obsessed hey why are you
so obsessed with me hey you [ __ ]
losers you're obsessed
you [ __ ] idiots you obsessive idiots
and look i i have been to the website
and i saw okay this is oh he doesn't
know about it but he has been to the
website
uh-huh this is why people are saying
that because i did look into that okay
they say something about a great reset i
don't look into it anymore than that
contrary to popular belief even if you
have one eye you could still can read
the same amount of things as somebody
with two eyes so this is a really bad
excuse no it's it's it's you get i gets
tired all right
having a pick up for the other eye it's
it's a bunch of people
it's it's an organization that has no
real power i mean
did he just say
the world economic forum
that is basically in completely run by
billionaires the richest people in the
[ __ ] planet
doesn't have any power
it's literally
a group
of
the most powerful people
that meet up every year
and
make plans for all of us it's literally
what it is out in the open they talk
about us not as people but we're ants
commodities
yeah there look there's always going to
be people that that maybe
i think what they mean by great reset is
the same thing the democrats are always
saying about about you know what kind of
infrastructure they want to invest in
redistribution of wealth that he thinks
one of the most evil organizations on
the planet is just worried about
infrastructure
they want to rebuild the bridges and
roads
he's a liar what he's doing is he's
pretending he doesn't know about what it
is but saying it's not important that
way he could still kind of stay
associated with them this all again
leads me to believe he's full of [ __ ]
that kind of thing more open immigration
i mean it's it's what you think it is i
believe
i think listen to how this [ __ ] is
talking bro i don't know man it's like
whatevs
that's what i heard my buddy you know
brett told me that i don't know man it's
like whatevs
um but
you know
i think when you call it the great reset
it's sort of it's sort of it sort of
indicates that there's like a secret
you know power cabal under it all
yeah dude
and since
you believe they're our greatest ally
and want to give them money you won't
say who they are i get you buddy i feel
you i'm re i i could see i got you homie
i got you i'm gonna dot the lowercase
j's
nice reference thanks
and it's not so secret it's just the
democrat party so like again i i just
want us to like take a step back like
it's not it's not a conspiracy it's a it
is a political platform
but just like just
you know it's not a concern why are you
if you don't know much about it why are
you panicking
exactly
panicking relax buddy
we sound a little crazy
you sound like you're about to say i
just wanted to watch wrestlemania
do you understand dan
come on
before we start talking about like some
sort of like secret
secret cabal um just fight the democrats
it's the same thing
it's just the democrats just fight the
democrats it's the same
thing
it's the same thing
are we gonna die yeah probably
dan crenshaw melts down
after being called out by wendy roger
and others for voting to create a
vaccine database now wendy roger if you
remember is the super [ __ ] basement
that said fed boy summer remember we
covered her oh yeah yeah yeah yeah she
ate a lot of [ __ ] for that she called
out crenshaw u.s house representative
dan crenshaw was among 80 house
republicans who voted for a bill to
create a vaccine database there's no
secret cabal there's no great reset
there's no people tracking
guys
crenshaw now denies however that the
bill does that after gop arizona senator
state
wendy rogers and others have called them
out for voting in favor of it
so you're just too stupid to get it
how does he
just all he does is just deadpan and go
yeah you're lying and it's like clearly
nobody's lying this is
completely accurate information and it's
like no
you're lying
okay i haven't seen this this actually
hold on let me actually put this in a
picture i just saw this because i was
scrolling to see if there's any more
stuff
this is actually it's it's poorly
photoshopped but it is funny
alex it's afraid
he's been having a little bit of a
meltdown over this yeah no seriously